when it comes to horror movies we've
seen it all aliens werewolves vampires
homicidal clowns and even creepy dolls I
don't believe it I just don't believe it
with so much shock factor already out of
the way though there are still some
movies that catch us off-guard
especially those with endings that are
horrifying head scratchers nothing
scarier than walking away from a movie
confused so let's dive right into our
nightmares and try to get some of these
confusing horror movie endings explained
the shining Stanley Kubrick's iconic
interpretation of Stephen King's novel
The Shining took a lot of liberties of
the source material and turned what was
an elaborate Hotel story into something
much more cerebral
the psychic concept of Shining has
spawned countless books and
documentaries which have tried to make
sense of the movie but one thing we can
all agree on is that after trying to
murder his wife and son Jack Nicholson's
character most definitely froze to death
outside of the Overlook Hotel there at
the end yep Dead fans might remember the
site of Dalian Wendy torrents escaping
in a snowmobile as the movie ends with a
close-up of a framed photo hanging in
the presumably haunted hotel the picture
is dated July 4th 1921 with Jack
Torrance smiling in front of a crowd of
partygoers which understandably is
pretty perplexing some of theorize that
Kubrick a stickler for details in his
movies specifically posed Nicholson like
this as a reference to old
eighteenth-century drawings of the devil
this would suggest that dole boy Jack
went to hell for trying to kill his
family regardless of whether his rampage
was caused by the ghosts of the hotel or
a particularly nasty strain of cabin
fever Jacob's Ladder the 1990
psychological thriller Jacob's Ladder
features Tim Robbins as Jacob singer a
Vietnam War vet who was stabbed by a
bayonet on the battlefield and returns
to the States to a whole new life where
his cosy pre-war role as a husband and
father is just a memory before being
shipped off to the battlefield Jacob had
a wife and three sons the youngest of
whom Gabe died before he deployed after
returning from the war he moves in with
new girlfriend Jesse but suffers from
nightmarish visions of monsters on other
surreal imagery the film bounces back
and forth between Jacobs realities from
his future life of Jesse to his past
family while he believes he's
experiencing some kind of after a
effect from a chemical agent he was
exposed to in Vietnam even worse the
events of the movie are revealed to be
only happening in his mind or while he
lay dying from a stab wound on the field
just before the triage doctors declare
him dead
Jacob Bentley goes home to his apartment
before the war and reunites with Gabe
who leads his father up their home
staircase into a bright light it's all
pretty complicated but in the end the
final scenes seemed to mean that Jacob
had finally found peace in the afterlife
in the mouth of madness John Carpenter's
in the mouth of badness lived up to its
name by going off the deep end in ways
that would make HP Lovecraft blush and
even out did inception with its story
within a story metafiction motif in the
movie Sam Neill plays John Trent an
insurance investigator sent to look for
a famous record-breaking horror author
named Sutter cane a moniker meant to pay
homage to author Stephen King Cain goes
missing just as his next bestseller
take a wild guess what it's called was
expected to break World Records so Trent
tracks off to New England to search for
the author and ends up reliving many
parts of Cain's stories in the movie
Cain's novel is so embraced by the
masses that his stories actually unleash
a bunch of deities from another
dimension intent on taking over the
world and Trent discovers he's actually
just a character in Cain's story a piece
of fiction what's even crazier is that
Cain turns out to be the portal through
which sees monsters emerged Niels
character eventually wakes up in a
run-down psychiatric ward and discovered
the world around him descending into
hell with widespread suicides and
murders as monsters roam the earth
through all the madness of foot
Trent finds a movie theater playing the
theatrical version of Cain's book and in
another layer of weird the movie replays
all of his experiences firming that he
really was a cetacaine character all
along and only became real as the story
unfolded did you get all that
let the right one in this Swedish
vampire love story and we're talking
about the original here not the 2010
remake
Let Me In introduces Oscar a 12 year old
bully victim who makes pals with a
secret blood drinker named Ely Oscar
wants revenge against his cool
school-aged tormentors and Ely is also
happy to oblige but there's a catch see
Ely lives of an old man named Harkin who
tries to get in the way of
because relationship with Ely because he
doesn't want to be replaced as her food
source provider Harkin is eventually
caught in the act of scaring up some
lunch for the girl and splashes acid on
his face to keep his identity secret
before offering up his own life as a
drink for Ely at the end of the movie
after Ellie's done away with the meanies
in Oscars life the to run away together
and their last scene together shows Ely
in a large box next to Oscar on a train
talking to each other through Morse code
it looks like Oscar is probably on his
way to growing old and repeating the
life of the late harken it was probably
once a little boy who loved Ely too and
the film ends on that suggestive note
just as Yan ad vid linguist novel of the
same name hurt however the movie
neglects to include the author's
epilogue linguist didn't like the
popular theory that Oscar was becoming
the new Harkin at the end of the story
and penned a subsequent short story
called let the old dreams die which
shows Ely and Oscar in a photo from 2008
almost three decades after the events of
the story the couple still appears young
and in love implying that Oscar actually
joins his girlfriend in a mortal and
deadness thanks for watching for more
spooky videos our friends at grunge
recently published a video about the
scariest clowns caught on camera click
the video here or the link in our
description to watch it now if you like
looper you'll love crunch the same team
makes videos for both channels